what do we mean by height
consider any plane surface like this
and assumes then is standing on it
how do you measure his height
you consider the distance between his
head and this surface
but do you measure it this way
or this way or this way
yes we measure it straight
this is also called the altitude it is
the perpendicular distance from a point
to a line or a surface
altitude is also defined as the shortest
distance between a point and a line
if we consider this person's head a
point
then this length is the shortest as
compared to any other lens from his head
to the surface
consider a segment bc and point a
somewhere over it
this perpendicular distance from point a
to d is called the altitude
a d is called the altitude
it is also the shortest distance between
point a and b c
remember it's also called the
perpendicular distance from a point to
the line
if we draw three random lines from point
a to e f and g
we should notice that all three lengths
are greater than the altitude a d
a e a f and a g
all three lengths are greater than
length a d
you